[Musik]
jugendliche gehen für ihre anliegen auf
die straße aber die bohne dürfen sie
nicht
abstimmen es ist so wir unsere zukunft
und nicht zukunft 74 jährige liegt in
unserem system
entscheiden die alten die wahlen und
dass es eigentlich demokratisch gesehen
ungerecht warum ist es so dass nicht
jede stimme zählt die grenzen der
partizipation und wie man sie überwinden
könnte
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja wir
machen heute station hier in der kaserne
basel wir werden allerdings schon lange
keine gewehre menge putz die kaserne ist
vielmehr ein etabliertes zentrum der
alternativkultur hier in basel
ja und die kaserne ist auch ein ort der
mitsprache genau darum geht es bei uns
heute und partizipation auf kultureller
politischer ebene denn aktuell ist das
in der schweiz so dass eben nicht jede
stimme zählt das also nicht alle mit
entscheiden können und darüber wollen
wir heute sprechen
[Musik]
wer eigentlich sind ja fast alle dafür
um doch existiert es noch immer nichts
das stimmrechtsalter 16 in der schweiz
einzige ausnahme der kanton glarus ja
warum eigentlich dürfen junge menschen
mit 16 oder 17 ganz vieles traktorfahren
sechs haben trinken aber politisch
mitbestimmen
das dürfen sie nicht warum ist das so
und wer bestimmt wann wir wo für reif
genug sind dazu unternehmen wir jetzt
eine tudor iso einmal quer durch die
schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seine stimme erheben sagen was man denkt
das ist wichtig in einer demokratie
zumal in der schweizerischen doch wer
wann was sagen kann dass entscheiden
immer jene die das sagen schon tragen
und die mögen es nicht besonders wenn
sie herausgefordert werden
insbesondere nicht von der jagd
[Musik]
[Applaus]
keine vier minuten wo sich engagiere
sich um ihre zukunft wo sie für ihre
züge die sätze und darum danke ich war
das ein guter schritt wenn man mit sack
und mitbestimmen was wir denn jetzt
sicher sehr entgegenkommen ich würde
sagen
jetzt gerade nicht bei allen
abstimmungen können abstimmen sondern
ich müsste mich erst darüber informieren
und alles aber dann würde schon sagen ja
ich
glaube es ist eigentlich gut wenn die
jüngere abstimmen wie es sich ereignet
so wir unsere zukunft und die zukunft
von 70 jährige vor dem eigentlich es
macht schon einen unterschied
obwohl von bergen umgeben ist globus der
progressivste kanton der schweiz punkto
mitsprache bereits 1967 beschlossen die
glarner männer an der landsgemeinde ein
partielles stimm und wahlrecht für
frauen also für eine bis dahin
marginalisierte gruppe die bekanntlich
erst 1971 gesamtschweizerisch
mitbestimmen durfte
und führten 2007 schließlich das
stimmrecht für 16 jährige ein ich hoffe
dass sätze für die anderen konnten dass
sie mitziehen den posten auschwitz
wieder dick für
das hat aber bisher nicht funktioniert
alle vorstöße dies zu ändern sind in
sämtlichen kantonen verworfen worden
zuletzt 2020 im kanton neuenburg denn
mit 16 sei man schließlich noch
minderjährig
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich dass die bevölkerung
des kantons neuenburg heute vernünftig
entschieden hat wir haben ein in sich
stimmiges system man ist bei uns mit 18
volljährig strafrechtlich und
zivilrechtlich und nicht mit 16
wer abstimmen geht muss also volljährig
sein so handhaben als die meisten länder
weltweit die
wissenschaft traute jugend mehr zu naja
dass sie minderjährig sind hat ja
irgendwann mal irgendein gesetz
festgelegt und
das ist eigentlich wie eine willkürliche
grenze für mich wäre interessanter die
frage verfügen sie über die fähigkeiten
die wir denken dass man sie braucht wenn
man abstimmen geht also können sie sich
ein differenziertes urteil bilden können
sie sich informationen zusammensuchen
können sie überlegen was sind meine
werte was sind meine interessen wo stehe
ich in zehn jahren was wird mir in zehn
jahren wichtig sein und das können die
jugendlichen und deswegen ist diese
altersgrenze 18 oder 21 ist so ein
bisschen willkürlich
trotzdem befand eine mehrheit des
stimmvolks 1991 die zeit sei reif und
führte so in der schweiz
stimmrechtsalter 18 1 zuvor lag es bei
20 den anderen ländern bei 21 oder sogar
bei 24 jahren und war bekanntlich den
männern vorbehalten
und wieso sie als diese trachten in der
haut
80 genauso eine willkürliche zahl wie
und ich kann das gefühl dass jeder
mensch unterschiedlich ist auch für
politik interessiert oder nicht und die
wand und sich dafür interessieren der
mit 16 abstimmen
auch wenn die wissenschaft die sache
entspannt sieht die regeln bestimmt die
politik
an antiken griechischen philosophen der
hatte gemeint eigentlich erst mit 50 in
die politik richtig gehen und darüber
lachen wir heute aber andererseits mit
49 ist man in italien noch nicht reif
genug um staatsoberhaupt zu werden und
frankreich reichen 18 und dann ist schon
interessant dass man in zwei
europäischen ländern zu unterschiedlich
schnell reifen kann und wann sind wir
reif genug eigentlich von anfang an bei
der geburt denn jeder hat das recht an
der gestaltung der öffentlichen
angelegenheiten seines landes
mitzuwirken
besagt die allgemeine erklärung der
menschenrechte
klar dass die herabsetzung des
wahlalters auf 16 noch gar nicht weit
genug geht weil es grundsätzlich
problematisch ist das wahlrecht mit
einer starren altersgrenze zu versehen
also eine familie mit zb zwei kindern
besteht ja aus vier menschen und der
vorschlag ist dass diese vier menschen
jeweils eine stimme bekommen in dem fall
wird die stimme von kleinen kindern
erstmal vertretungs halber von ihren
eltern wahrgenommen aber es sind vier
menschen und die sollten auch vier
stimmen bekommen in unserem system
entscheiden die alten die wahlen und
dass es eigentlich demokratisch gesehen
ungerecht will heißen was jetzt
entschieden wird trifft die jungen viel
mehr als die alten wenn die alten also
den jungen keine stimme geben wollen
dann drehe ich den spieß halt um dachte
sich polo hofer 1991 und forderte
kein stimmrecht mehr für leute über 70
startzeit geben leicht ab 70 jahren und
nachher dies wolfgang
wieder gestellt haben sagt ein alter
bekannter
herford das sakrament das ich aber bis
kurz vor hunter junge gegenüber
version 8 mw ladens erfuhr ich dass ich
alle wichtigen punkt darauf unternimmt
und wir führen sie haben unter ladens
funk reguliert sondern bestimmen und
wenn dann unterzieht
engagement gibt es bei jung und alt
können die jungen aber nicht
mitbestimmen gehen sie auf die straße
und schüren so das vorurteil links-grün
indoktriniert zu sein
natürlich sind junge menschen
beeinflussbar aber wir sind auch alle
beeinflusst 430 sind 50 oder 60 wir sind
beeinflussbar und das ist bei jugend bei
jungen menschen auch so da gibt es
einfach keinen unterschied zwischen 16
und 18 jährigen
wer keinen unterschied macht zwischen 16
und 18 sind österreich und malta sie
kennen das wahlrechtsalter 16 bereits
der sozialismus ist deshalb nicht
eingeführt worden die ganz jungen stimme
nicht signifikant anders als die nicht
mehr ganz jung wenn sie überhaupt wählen
gehen
interessanterweise haben wir seit 5000
jahren machen wir der jugend den vorwurf
sie sei inkompetent und
verantwortungslos wir haben dokumente
von den sumerern
seit 5000 jahren und jede generation
glaubt aufs neue um ihre jugend steht es
ganz besonders schlimm auch das sind
große konstante und selbst wenn das
stimmen würde
dann hätten wir in 5000 jahren immer
noch nicht gelernt dass wir die jugend
gerade deshalb einschließen müssen damit
sie eben kompetenter und
verantwortungsbewusste würden
sie reden laut stadt nichts die
jugendlichen warum also nicht diese
kraft an der urne nutzen die direkte
demokratie dürfte das locker aushalten
am börse der kaserne basel ist es
matthäus sich experten für bildung und
diversität und engagiert für mehr
partizipation des matthäus was wird sich
dann für als alle vfr bessere mannschaft
sein darf damit bestimme ich glaube dass
ein gesellschafter so vielfältig
aufgestellt ist wie unser großes
interesse braucht dass er möglichst
vielfältige stimmt mittwochabend
demokratische mitbestimmung nicht ob man
da gestaltung eigentlich für die zukunft
vielfältig ist ja super war maria alle
und doch wie muss man sich fragen sind
dann die nation sind jetzt unrechts und
keine politische entscheidung mitteilen
das ist eine klassische frage hat man
sich bei der frau übrigens eingestellt
50 jahre von der marktfrau ändert das
gar nicht die von der garnituren blicken
was politisch politiker otto die
körnigen den kuchen und das sagt man
jetzt wieder mit der junge migranten
migrant innen wo kein stimmrecht an ich
glaube menschen mitbestimmen die hannah
im prinzip in trance sich zu informieren
und mein gesicht bilden und darum glaube
ich nicht dass menschen mit zu 80 das
wäre schon mal als ganzes an das bild
von der schweizer mannschaft sagt anita
mitbestimmen es gibt aber noch mehr luft
nach oben nämlich alle diamant wohl kein
schweizer pass hat wer aue möglichkeit
dass die dörfer mitbestimmen was würde
das bedeuten dass über das ein viertel
der schweizer bevölkerung zwei millionen
schweizer post im moment in der schweiz
aber sie schauen könnte beteiligen und
ich glaube extremes interesse dass
menschen mit migrationsgeschichte und
menschen vor allem wo in der schweiz
sich können beteiligen und was passiert
damit der typische schweizer wehrte sich
jetzt viele fragen wie wie zelten die
mitsprache tatsächlich die mit spruch
muss sowieso wie es überhaupt möglich
ist also ich glaube wenn ich sie jetzt
wird gegen fragen was denn eigentlich
die klassische swift verwaltet wird und
maschinen seine ganzen diskussionen aber
vielleicht gott sagen die uns handlich
was ist denn eigentlich was sind
schweizer ich würde nicht sagen dass die
schweiz so weit sind wir nur vorträge
100 jahre und die verhandler sind sie
werden jetzt nicht so wichtig den 30
und dir vor antritt der prozess wo man
miteinander aushandeln soll möglichst
keine toten
allerdings muss man sich überlegt was
passiert dann mit einem wert von mir aus
der kampf ich sage das frauenstimmrecht
weil diesmal wert unserer kultur nicht
überschäumend aber das passiert dann
nahmen rad ab sachlich es würde so ganz
konservativ war plötzlich ins spiel über
seine partizipation vor allem wo wann
und zum beispiel frauenrechte schnittig
war die erste für da kam für logisch
aber ich glaube das war genau der punkt
wo minister aus browns nehmen ist das
haben wir aus der nato minister sagen
das sind unsere
hinter der linie und das wird natürlich
demokratische
demokratischer diskurs über das was uns
ist und wo wichtig ist unterstützt
natürlich ganz anders entfachen die
kompetenz von der sehr verschlossen
halten wenn es dann wirklich und
nationalitäten zusammen eröffnet wo
ihnen vorschwebt konsequent vision ist
ali ali ali sollen mitbestimmen können
wo sind da haben dann kann man nicht
sagen ob man dafür alle wo einfach da
sind mitbestimmen dann geht es immer die
diskussionen auch wenn über zwei
millionen menschen in der schweiz in
über 50 prozent in überzahl mit 1 2
wenn das lied beruhigt einfach zumal in
das experiment ihnen dass das eigentlich
heißt wenn menschen mitbestimmen ich
muss nicht verfangen
geflüchtete menschen obwohl ich rein als
vision das großartig fand ab und ich
kann es ein kleiner schritt machen ich
hoffe und ich weiß wie politik
funktioniert das danke für das gespräch
eines materials vielen dank
mitbestimmung das ist auch in der kultur
ein großes thema denn die kulturhäuser
müssen sich überlegen wie sie auch in
zukunft ihr publikum finden und
einbinden und auch die kulturförderung
öffnet sich und verlässt sich in zukunft
nicht mehr nur auf das urteil von
expertinnen und experten
partizipation das ist also auch in der
kultur weit mehr als nur ein trend
alle kultur teilhaben lassen diverser
bunter vielfältiger werden das haben
sich viele schweizer kulturhäuser
vorgenommen und für die zukunft fit zu
sein und in einer sich wandelnden
gesellschaft relevant zu bleiben in
diesem veränderungsprozess wenden sich
immer mehr institutionen an die
schweizer kulturstiftung pro helvetia
merkt man dass für andere wandels aber
semi wand neue zielgruppe erreichen mit
frauen an frauen als neues publikum
ansprechen sie hat aber häufig mit zieht
sie hat mit ressourcen sie wissen genau
wie sie das land und genau da möchte man
sätze wie das innovative idee eine
ausschreibung mit namen tandem
diversität dabei sollen coaches die
institutionen unterstützen sich für mehr
diversität und chancengleichheit
einzusetzen beim personal im programm
und beim publikum
für diese fördermaßnahme ist serena
rohrer zuständig sie leitet seit 2020
bei pro helvetia den bereich innovation
und gesellschaft dieses jahr vergab sie
im rahmen von tandem diversität den
höchsten förderbeitrag von 50000 franken
an die bühnen beim
das große haus mit seinen vier sparten
oper schauspiel ballett und konzert hat
sich viel vorgenommen
steht aber noch am anfang
laut der neuen chef der matur genannt
schauspiel beenden wird das diversität
coaching über drei jahre hinweg
gefördert die entwicklung soll
nachhaltig sein das ist für die zürcher
wichtig
wir haben jetzt sicherstellen dass der
fokus aber auf
verschiedene menschen verschiedene
hintergrund verschiedenen blickwinkeln
wäre das einfach zu kalt das muss dass
es nach einer mühle weg gut also dass
das man den blickwinkel mehr frauen
menschen mit migrationsgeschichte
menschen mit bestimmten reinkriegen
vielleicht auch jetzt im physischen
bereich
wäre der blick so frankfurt werden dass
meine verläuft dieser prozess beginnt
erst aber ein starter projekt gibt es
schon das schauspiel mobil das motto
heißt hinaus aus dem theater in die
stadt in den kantonen spielen an anderen
orten in gemeindesälen schulen
jugendzentren
der wunsch so hoffentlich auch
limited die schwelle bis jetzt nicht
ungern überschreitet oder vielleicht
sich nicht so repräsentiert fühlen im
hochsommer herausstellen demnach ist für
bestimmte menschen einfach zu mir eben
nicht bloß zuschauen gar mitbestimmen
das ist die idee hinter einem projekt
das in winterthur im gange ist die
private stiftung für kunst kultur und
geschichte hat die zwei kulturmanagerin
mehr odermatt und noemi scheurer damit
beauftragt ein neues modell der
kulturförderung auszuprobieren
sie haben 200 briefe an die winterthurer
bevölkerung verschickt an zufällig
ausgewählte menschen diese sollen ein
kultur komitee bilden und entscheiden
welche winterthurer kultur projekte
gefördert werden sollen
mit der kultur kultur kultur das ist
kultur und wer entscheidet was grund
tourismusverbandes kultur ist und der
tvi probieren damit andere aktiv
erinnert bringt andere
perspektiven
von kultur kommen
auf den briefen haben sich 25 menschen
gemeldet die mitmachen wollen im alter
von 19 bis 80 jahren
das ist leider absagen
wir hatten heraus antwortet ich kann
nicht dabei sein altershalber jahrgang
winter eine
anfangs jahr
seien entscheide stadt expertenwissen
bei einem budget von insgesamt 400.000
franken mit denen winterthurer
kulturschaffende gefördert werden können
ist das ein wagnis
es brauchte mut entscheidungsmacht
verbunden mit 430 franken
ausgeschüttet war der projekttag
mit
einer frage was mitbringt was passiert
wenn mancher latella kulturförderung
dass kultur komitee winterthur
und die bühnen bern
beide nähren sie die hoffnung auf einen
zeitgemäßen kulturbetrieb divers
vielfältig und zur bunt wie die fahnen
am berner stadttheater
[Musik]
sandra lohn sie sind der leiter der
kaserne basel und sie sind schon länger
auf dem weg zur partizipation wieso
lohnt sich das
kunst kultur führen weiter von der stadt
zu machen macht immer sinn auch die
mannschaft wirklich speziell mit
beteiligen also meine prozesse sind
trasse stieg dadurch in eine ganz andere
form der beteiligung aktiv sicher -
rennes beteiligen gibt ein völliger
unterbezirk zu unruhig frage wie
funktioniert das konkret ich habe mir
überhaupt der die lykaner wir den wir
ihn überzeugen dass sie dass sie sich da
engagiert ja das sind welche prozess
wohl primär aber zwei menschen die so
genannte vermittler tätig sind die
tierversuche wirklich thematisch
inhaltlich vernünftige herzustellen und
dann gibt es eben jetzt musik ihre
grandiose türkische band versucht man
wirklich dass die basler türkischen
bevölkerung wirklich weiß dass es
stattfindet und die beziehungen zu
knüpfen oder dann sehr schönes projekt
utopia
ist das projekt wurde im juni wartet
noch mit 83 aus dem kreisel wo ich vier
verein sich gegenseitig treffe die
verein und quasi zur zukunft von basel
verhandelt haben sich jetzt vorstellt
dass ich alles sehr neu mischen und
alles steht zur disposition muss man
sagen andere lohn ihrer stuhl als alte
wissen als chef vom fuß steht ziemlich
zudem absolut was hatte ich ein guter
geist und teile da also da ist sehr
wichtig dass man sich wirklich modell
und dankt wirtschaft aber das
hausinterne stellt auf der einen seite
ist eine wirklich mit flachen jedoch
hier schafft ihr rekrutieren und
personal etc zentral ist dass die
potters im innenhof dass man kunst
chance da auf der bühne gesehen eine
große selbstverständlichkeit die
mit verschiedenen sexuellen dingen ganz
großer normalität in denen es an
verständlichkeit und dass man nicht
permanent das hoffe ich sehr dass wir
das einmal
wir sind ein weg für deinen rarität und
große stücke er hat die realität ist da
die stadt aber auf die bi nicht auf dem
niveau im prozess und im
klimatologischen wieso sagen das ist dem
personal weniger klar spürbar und am
schluss vom tag für wen mühen der
wandern theatermacher man wird nie
variante also verständlich und kunst und
kritiker diese kunst kultur wird immer
ausschluss produzieren aber sich mit
denen wirklich auseinandersetzen und
jetzt versuchen
hoffnungsträger das macht sehr viel spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben es bestimmt auch schon
mitbekommen wie von kulturplatz sind
inzwischen auch auf instagram präsent
reinschauen lohnt sich sie lernen dort
kreative aller couleur kennen so wie zum
beispiel den zeichner und illustrator
tobias gut man meinen kolleginnen
demokratie und hat ihn an einem wärmeren
tag in zürich getroffen
tobias gutmann eine farbexplosion auf
zwei beinen mit einer großen
leidenschaft protest über 5000 menschen
hat er schon gezeichnet und heute heute
bin ich gern wir haben klar dass du
jeden tag eine stunde durch verzeichnen
ja das ist ideal
also ich sehe jetzt zum beispiel andere
technik die öffentlichkeit bei denen
verspannt ist
mein gesicht auf strenge kritik
er habe den kopfhörer
machen naja wahrscheinlich also dahin
wirklich angestrengt versucht nichts
machen und sie sind unsere
sein größtes künstliches projekt ist der
phaser markt das ist eine art selbst
gebastelte kiste darin zeichnete er dann
seine prozess
es geht nur um die technik sondern es
geht ums ganze geht um die technik es
geht um ruhm es geht darum dass sobald
du in so mancher trittin fürs erste teil
von denen kunstwerke lassen
es ist immer noch recht wichtig dass
wenn ihr da zeichnet dass die person
oder hockt gesagt nicht warum ist es
wichtig es ist einfach irgendwie
personen mit er erwarte hier das ist
fotos er wusste hanne zeichner ohne das
ist schon
[Gelächter]
okay jetzt bin ich schon aber
ich
[Musik]
mache so machen facelift als sieben
achtel facelift
in fässern ich versuche ortung von
personen fest sollte also nicht nur das
onyx und maniküre und das wohl nie
gespürt das ist nur dass wenn ich mit
meinen augen sehe
[Musik]
seine rolle aber so ganz bewusst in die
deutschen bekannt der wissenschafter die
ruhe genau
dies ist jetzt geklärt
seit neun jahren twitter künstler durch
die ganze welt er hat schon menschen in
dubai porträtiert in tansania china sind
korea gefühlt fast überall
[Musik]
als erster film mord bild entstand in
schweden während eines austauschs
semesters übrigens geboren ist tobias
gutmann in papua neuguinea eine kleine
insel im südwestlichen pazifik und ja
auch dort war er schon zeichnen tätig
zurück in zürich
[Musik]
st
die zweite punkt die augen geschlossen
aber es ist einfach so einen blick
die nicht auf der mensch verändert
nach sichtung sportkreis ja
ganz sicher frag ich mich
glaub das problem für insider ist es
neben stereotypisierung europäischem
einschließlich hut roten haaren anlass
wieder leicht und für mehr ist sie
schwanger ist wichtig sie das irgendwie
versuchte etc mit unbedingt ist die
schublade für zoller und aspecton nach
für stoss ich
noch eine woche und überall und
ersatzspielerin mensch
[Musik]
hsf kultur auf instagram das bedeutet
auch aktive partizipation und zwar könnt
ihr unseren host auf instagram eine
nachricht schicken wenn ihr junge
kunstschaffende seid dann seht ihr
vielleicht euro arbeiten schon bald auf
unserem kanal
nächste woche das schauen wir zur
klimakonferenz nach glasgow und stellen
die frage wie kunstschaffende mit dem
thema klimawandel umgehen und gleich
jetzt folgt auf sf1 die sternstunde
philosophie mit dem inneren philippe
petit zur frage welche freiheit uns
befreit kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]